[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pris la route de Dijon pour voir un
peu la margeolain la belle digue
diguedon qui pleurait près de la
fontaine mais elle avait changé le ton
il lui fallait des ducatons dedans son
bas de lainee pour n'avoir plus de peine
elle m'a dit tu viens chéri et si tu me
payes un bon prix aux anges je t'emmène
dig dig don la Marjoline pleurait
surtout
quand elle n'avait pas de
s la margeoline de la
chanson avait de plus nobl
façon j'ai passé le pont d'abignon pour
voir un peu les belles dames et les
beaux messieurs tous en rond qui
dansaient dans ses corps et âmes mais
ils avaient changé de ton il faisaient
filer rigodon menu et Pavan tentelle
sardane et les belles dames ceci
étranger sauve-toi d'ici où l'on donne
l'alarme aux chiens et aux gendarmes
quelle mouche les a don
piqué ces belles-dames si
distinguées les belles-dames de la
chanson avait de plus nobles
façon je me suis fait faire prisonnier
dans les vieilles prisons de Nant pour
voir la fille du jolier qui paraî-il est
venante mais elle avait changé de ton
quand j'ai demandé que diton des
affaires courantes dans la ville de Nant
la mignonne m'a répondu on dit que vous
serez pendu au matine sonnante et j'en
suis bien contente les jolières n'ont
plus de cœur au prisons de Nant et
d'ailleurs la jolière de la
chanson avait de plus noble
façon vousou l' mener à bonne fin ma
folle course vagabonde vers mes pénates
je revins pour dormir auprès de ma
blonde mais elle avait changé de ton
avec elle sous les dredon il y avait du
monde dormant près de ma blonde j'ai
pris de coups d'un air blagueur mais en
cachette dans mon cœur la peine était
profonde le chagrin lâcher la bonde
hélas du jardin de mon
père la colombe s'est fait la
paè par bonheur par
consolation me sont resté les quatre
[Musique]
chansons